[Music]
when we're born we have a very small
view of the world our mother's womb and
the delivery room and as you raised your
parents are probably trying to control
the environment that you're in and so
you end up with a very centralized tiny
little view of the world naturally as
you get older as you travel more as you
read more you start to understand a
little more of the world around you and
all of those influences affect your
choices in life what are you going to
imagine that you could be if you've
never left Main Street small town Ohio
then you're probably not going to
visualize yourself doing something that
is wildly different than that you're
never going to be the head of a
religious sect in in Pakistan you know
it's just it's it's not inside your
worldview you-you-you can only draw your
own aspirations and hopes and decisions
based on the things that you even know
exist it's easier now to understand and
see the world than ever in history our
ability to communicate and our ability
to travel has greatly improved but space
travel is sort of like the wildly
exaggerated version of that where you
can go around the whole world and the
time it takes to eat supper and see
everywhere I see the whole world sixteen
times a day that widens and deepens your
worldview like nothing we've ever seen
before in history and it's very
difficult to maintain artificially drawn
biases like like nationalistic borders
and you know my little tribe my little
street my little gang my little town my
little whatever when 15 minutes later
you're over the exact the same looking
sort of town but it's in Africa and 40
minutes later at the exact same looking
sort of town and it's in Australia and
then you come up Indonesia and you go
man it's it's all the same they build
the towns just like we build our towns
and and what's how are they they then
it's just sort of all us we're all doing
this thing together and everyone's got
the same sort of hopes and dreams
amongst themselves and that pervasive
sense
of the shared collective experience of
being a human being that seeps into you
onboard a spaceship not the first time
around
first times overwhelming but somewhere
you know hundred times around 500 times
around suddenly the world becomes one
place in your mind it's not very big and
and that I think is a really important
worldview to have life can be full of
magnificent experiences you know being
at the wedding of a loved one in a
beautiful big house of worship somewhere
where there's the sound and the beauty
and the structure it it affects how you
feel that day and you act a little bit
differently or walking into a gigantic
ancient redwood forest your head is
naturally drawn upwards and and you
think a little different it's not the
same as just walking down your street
I'll imagine what it's like on a
spaceship where you're floating
weightless at a window where you see an
entire continent in in the time it takes
to drink a cup of coffee where you go
from LA to New York in nine minutes
and you see all of that history and
culture and climate and and geography
and geology and it's all right there
underneath you and you see a sunrise or
a sunset every 45 minutes you see the
world for what it actually is it has
that same sort of personal effect on you
of a feeling of privilege and sort of a
reverence and awe that that is pervasive
when we're floating in the in the
bulging window the Coupole of the space
station normally it's just one person
because everybody's busy but if there's
two of you in there you talk in hushed
tones to each other just because you
feel like you're just wildly lucky to
even be there to see this happening and
that sense of wonder and privilege and
clarity of the world slowly shifts your
view of course your understanding of
what is us and what is them what is old
and what is new what does four billion
years actually mean
you know where you can see where the ice
ages word you can see where the
volcanoes were and the huge asteroid
impacts and such and it all starts to
sort of shift in your head there was a
fella in the late 60s early 70s who
wrote a book sort of trying to capture
that he called it the overview effect
you can call it whatever you like it
doesn't have to be involved with
spaceflight it's more when you sense
that there is something so much bigger
than you so much more deep than you are
ancient has sort of a natural importance
that Dwarfs your own but you're a person
seeing it you're a person that's
interpreting it you're you're
understanding it in your own way and
you'd have to be a stone to not have
that affect you it it's it changes how
you think about things but it's not the
same for everybody and it's not
instantaneous it's not it's not like hey
I've gone over 60 miles an hour I'm you
know now we've done this thing it's it's
very much a gradual creeping improvement
in perception of the world around us I
think that's what the author was trying
to talk about when when he wrote about
the overview effect and some people are
much more emotive and it affects them
very deeply some people they just have a
better understanding of the world itself
either way it's healthy it it's a
perspective of the world that allows us
hopefully to make better collective
global decisions about what's happening
less jealous narrow local decisions and
we need that type of thinking if we're
truly going to have this many people and
this standard of living for the
foreseeable future we just need to see
the world as one place the fact that
we're all in this together and that we
are in the position to actually
understand it and appreciate it and
therefore make different decisions about
it
[Music]
you